you know i told you over the last few
months that dr
anthony fauci who's the top infectious
disease doctor in the country
needs a security detail because of
threats against him
and we it's really a sort of glimpse a
peek behind the curtain into the
problems that we have as a country here
in the united states when the doctor
trying to stop
the pandemic and save people
has so many americans wanting to hurt
him
furious with him believing that he is
trying to hurt americans
targeting him as some kind of nefarious
player
in some bizarre amalgam of conspiracy
theories
involving uh bill gates and
microchipping and rfid and all sorts of
stuff
he needs security that's utterly
unconscionable think about how crazy it
is that in most
countries a pandemic comes
everybody defers to the public health
officials
and to the doctors who specialize in
infectious disease
not in the u.s in the u.s the pandemic
comes
and such a large portion of the country
is
furious with the doctors that the
doctors end up needing security to
protect them from americans
let that sink in well now it's even
worse
it's not just dr fauci who is at risk dr
fauci admitted earlier this week that
now
his daughters need security to protect
them because of the work that dr
fauci is doing dr fauci said he and his
family have required
continued security in the face of
harassment and death threats
because people are mad at what he is
doing
in terms of the coronavirus pandemic
trump said we have 15 cases which will
be zero soon in march
people are mad at dr fauci and
threatening his family a quote from a
recent interview he did with cnn
commenting on this dr fauci says the
unseemingly things that crises bring out
in the world
i don't know if unseemingly i don't know
if that makes sense but i'm quoting dr
fauci the unseemingly things that crises
bring out in the world
it brings out the best of people and the
worst of people and getting death
threats to my family
and harassing my daughters to the point
where i have to get security
it's amazing i wouldn't have imagined in
my wildest
dreams that people who object to things
that are
pure public health principles are so
set against it and don't like what you
say and i say
namely in the world of science that they
actually
threaten you i mean that to me is just
strange now what's really funny here
is that dr fauci during this interview
refers to there being a degree of
anti-science sentiment in the united
states
that is quite the understatement half
the country according to multiple polls
doesn't even plan
to get the coronavirus vaccine if and
when it is available to them
but this is this is a bigger issue this
anti-intellectualism that underlies all
of this has been growing for a long time
if you go back and read some of my
favorite authors like the work of carl
sagan from decades ago if you look at
what isaac asimov wrote
decades ago they saw it coming they've
been sounding the alarm about
not sort of benign anti-intellectualism
and anti-science and rejection of
science in the united states
they have been sounding the alarm about
the real world impact that it
was having and could potentially have
significantly more of
they were completely correct and for all
of these folks who talk about as
i mentioned yesterday trump derangement
syndrome which is just a term to stymie
debate
um we if anything have been not alarmist
enough about this issue of rejection of
science
anti-intellectualism and also
pseudo-intellectualism which presents
its own set of risks that i've
previously discussed
instead of revering our doctors and our
scientists
they've become enemies for i mean would
you say it's for
20 30 40 percent of the country imagine
threatening someone
for trying to help the american people
imagine
threatening the children of someone
trying to help
the american people and almost every day
americans find
new novel ways to make the united states
a laughing stock and a global
embarrassment and this is
in a sense as i mentioned you know when
i mentioned carl sagan and isaac
asimov this was predicted this is what
happens after
on the one hand decades of underfunding
schools
and not prioritizing understanding
science and critical thinking and
epistemology and you combine that with
the political party the republican party
that benefits from that raises money
on the basis of rejecting science uh
and also religiously based
reactionary ideas although that's not at
the core of what we're seeing now with
the virus necessarily
there are more components i'm i'm being
overly simplistic
but those are two big important pieces
of the analysis
imagine what it's like for dr fauci day
to day
going to work trying to deal with a
hundred year pandemic
seeing other countries successfully do
it
and knowing that not only are we failing
because of the president
but that the president is a huge part of
why
a large portion of the country hates dr
fauci some to the point that they would
like to see him dead
redoubling my sentiments from an earlier
segment
we owe the world an explanation and an
apology
and by the way for if trump wanted to
stop this
if donald trump spent a week saying
leave dr fauci alone i don't want to
hear
anything about anybody going after dr
fauci or threatening his family
his interest is the health of the
american people if trump did that
95 98 99 of this would stop but instead
trump is actually part of the problem
rather than the solution
imagine being a health expert in the
medical field
and having death threats hurled at you
and your family
for trying to protect the public and
having the president of the united
states
actually foment that treatment rather
than tell people
to stop and to cut it out for lack of a
better term
it's bad really really bad one of our
sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies
who you are you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but
if you want privacy also offers a ten
dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36
credit cards a month and a 25 a month
plan tailored more for small businesses
where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com pacman